[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
niedrige Serien schönen guten Abend
ihnen allen wieder gilt manche haben
Feiertag andere nicht was ich definitiv
habe ist Kristin Auto im Studio später
mit der Fußball Champions wird
spannender Abend guten Abend hier sind
unsere Themen
mit Tempo entlasten schon im Februar
könnte die gaspreisbremse kommen morgen
ringend Bund und Länder um die Details
schmerzhafte Einschnitte Galeria
Karstadt Kaufhof schließt ein Drittel
aller Filialen die Gewerkschaft verdi
will um jeden einzelnen Job kämpfen
und Mission Menschenrechte vor Beginn
der Fußball-WM holt sich Innenministerin
faesar in Katar Sicherheitsgarantien für
deutsche Fans ein
[Musik]
wochenlang schon streiten sich bunt und
Länder heftig darüber wer wie viele
Milliarden zur krisenentlastung
bereitstellt bevor morgen offiziell
weiter beraten wird kommen heute aus dem
Bundeskanzleramt Kompromissvorschläge
etwa die gaspreisbremse schon einen
Monat früher einzuführen Tobias Hefner
gibt uns einen Überblick über das was
auf dem Tisch liegt
eine der wichtigsten Neuerungen
gegenüber den bisher bekannten Fakten
das Kanzleramt will prüfen lassen ob die
vorgesehene gaspreisbremse bereits im
Februar 2023 greifen kann und nicht erst
wie ursprünglich geplant im März
beim Thema Strom sollen Privathaushalte
und kleinere Firmen schon ab Januar
entlastet werden der Preis pro
Kilowattstunde könnte für Sie bei 40
Cent gedeckelt werden für 80% des
erwarteten Verbrauchs
Industrieunternehmen zahlen demnach zur
Sicherung von Arbeitsplätzen nochmal
weniger 13 Cent pro Kilowattstunde
entlastet würden sie allerdings nur für
70% ihrer Verbrauchsprognose
finanziert werden soll das auch mit der
Abschöpfung von derzeitigen gewinnen der
Energieunternehmen
Entgegenkommen will der Bund den Ländern
offenbar beim Thema öffentlicher
Nahverkehr zusätzlich zu den
Bundesmitteln für die möglichst
schneller Einführung eines 49 Euro
Tickets soll es mehr Zuschüsse für
Investitionen in die regionalen
Verkehrsnetze geben
und auch bei den Kosten für die
geflüchteten in Deutschland etwa aus der
Ukraine will Berlin auf die Länder
finanziell zugehen
wir sprechen mit Shark conta la bernergy
in Berlin schakotela spannender
Milliarden Poker morgen wir sind denn
die Aussichten des Bund und Länder
schnell zusammenfinden also vermutlich
besser als bei der Sitzung Anfang
Oktober da ist man ja ohne Ergebnis
auseinander gegangen und das will man
dieses Mal auf jeden Fall vermeiden
deswegen gab es im Vorfeld auch
ordentlich Kommunikation Christian
Lindner und Robert Habeck sind vorletzte
Woche extra nochmal zu einer
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz nach
Hannover gefahren und haben dort Ideen
und Vorschläge diskutiert aber es kann
trotzdem sein dass es morgen zu einer
sehr langen Sitzung kommt denn am Ende
geht es ums Geld genauer gesagt um die
Lastenverteilung zwischen Bund und
Ländern und da haben die Länder bei
allen großen Punkten Sorge dass mit
jeder Milliarde die sie mehr in den Topf
werfen sollen ihre eigenen politischen
Spielräume eingeschränkt wird
und dass man dort deswegen können wir
erwarten dass dort hart gefeilscht wird
es geht um 15 Uhr los und das Interesse
ist auf allen Seiten hoch mit einigen
guten Einigungen rauszukommen weil man
eben auch nachweisen möchte dass man
hier in der Krise handlungsfähig ist und
Entlastungen gemeinsam beschließen kann
und wir werden das natürlich begleiten
Dankeschön für diese Eindrücke aus
Berlin und für diese Schilderungen
chakota la benergy und das Thema
Flüchtlinge wir haben es gehört ist ein
Thema zwischen Bund und Ländern genauer
gesagt die Finanzierung
2021 beantragten von Januar bis
September rund 90.000 Menschen Asyl in
Deutschland
2022 waren es im gleichen Zeitraum rund
126.000 Menschen das sind gut 40% mehr
die meisten kommen aus Syrien
Afghanistan und der Türkei und hinzu
kommen rund eine Million Schutzsuchende
aus der Ukraine und das überfordert
viele Kommunen Florian kocik berichtet
lange war hier nicht mehr so viel los
seit drei Jahren ist die Heiligenstädter
ibergschule geschlossen jetzt sind die
Klassenzimmer Zufluchtsort für
geflüchtete genau wie die ehemaligen
Abstellräume auf 8 m² leben hier gerade
fünf Personen wir sind überall in der
Kapazitätsgrenze angekommen heute reist
wieder ein Bus voll an von Suhl und
damit sind auch hier die letzten Betten
belegt um die Aufnahmekapazitäten zu
erhöhen will das Eichsfeld aus dieser
leerstehenden Halle in Leinefelde eine
Flüchtlingsunterkunft machen doch als
das Mitte Oktober bekannt wird werden
dagegen Unterschriften gesammelt und
anonyme protestmähers verschickt darin
auch Adressen und Telefonnummern am
Mietvertrag Beteiligter Person der
Landrat zieht die Notbremse wir haben
die Halle nicht in Betrieb genommen weil
wir die Befürchtung hatten es eskaliert
uns die Gefahr ist hochgekommen weil uns
das Land allein lässt ich erwarte von
dem Land dass das Land selbst ein
generalmanagement zur Unterbringung von
Flüchtlingen über nimmt und uns
mitwirken lässt auch andere Landkreise
sind am Limit deshalb will der Freistaat
in den nächsten Wochen weitere
Aufnahmeplätze schaffen wir hoffen 600
bis 800 Personen damit noch extra
unterbringen zu können und wenn der
Zustrom so bleibt werden wir auch
massenunterkünfte bereitstellen müssen
bis Jahresende rechnet Thüringen mit
weiteren 6000 Flüchtlingen 34.000 hat
das Land dieses Jahr bereits aufgenommen
und damit schon jetzt mehr als in der
flüchtlingskrise 2015
rund drei Wochen nach der Landtagswahl
in Niedersachsen haben SPD und Grüne
ihren Koalitionsvertrag vorgestellt
demnach soll die SPD 6 Ressource
übernehmen an die Grünen gehen 4
gemeinsam ist Ziel sind mehr
Investitionen in Bildung und Klimaschutz
die Zustimmung der beiden
Landesparteitage am Wochenende gilt als
wahrscheinlich nächste Woche soll dann
Stefan weil für eine dritte Amtszeit als
Ministerpräsident vereidigt werden
es ist eine ziemlich bittere Pille in
ohnehin sehr anstrengenden Zeiten am
bittersten für die Angestellten von
Galeria Karstadt Kaufhof gestern hatte
der kaufhauskonzern Insolvenzantrag
gestellt Galeria Karstadt Kaufhof ist
noch in allen Bundesländern vertreten
mit insgesamt 131 Kaufhäusern in manchen
Städten mehrere mindestens ein Drittel
davon also mehr als 40 will der Konzern
jetzt schließen welche Filialen das ist
noch nicht ganz klar vielen der gut
17.000 Beschäftigten droht die Kündigung
Sven Rieken berichtet
schon wieder angezählt man mag sich kaum
vorstellen wie die Stimmung in den
Filialen der letzten deutschen
Kaufhauskette wohl sein mag am
Personaleingang dieser Hamburger Filiale
möchte niemand aus der Belegschaft
kommentieren was die Geschäftsleitung
beschlossen hat
es hat uns kalt erwischt entsprechend
ist auch die Wut und Enttäuschung groß
gerade bei den Beschäftigten von Galeria
Karstadt Kaufhof die quasi wieder erneut
in die Situation geraten wie von vor
zwei Jahren um ihre Arbeitsplätze bangen
müssen schon in der ersten
sanierungsrunde hat das Unternehmen 40
Standorte geschlossen 5000 Mitarbeiter
mussten gehen das Geld aus dem
staatlichen Schutzschirm aber ist
aufgebraucht der Online-Handel hat in
der Pandemie stark zugelegt zu viele
Kunden haben sich abgewendet ich war
gerade in ureparatur bei Karstadt das
war eigentlich ganz praktisch
sonst bestell ich auch ganz viel online
ich bin schon sehr für osternsässig wir
haben einfach auch spontan was bekommen
nicht warten muss ich bin aber dieses
ganz hin und her geschickt mit den
Paketen schaust schwierig auch gerade
mit Klimawandel Klimaschutz muss man
auch bedenken schade gibt es ja
irgendwie schon seit Ewigkeiten aber ja
für die Leute tut's einem Halt Leid
diese Zeiten sind wohl endgültig vorbei
das Konzept Kaufhaus in der klassischen
Form ist nicht mit der Zeit gegangen
immer neue einsparrunden Bergen zudem
die Gefahr das Warenhäuser noch mehr an
Attraktivität verlieren dann will ich
doch in so einen Warenhaus gehen weil
ich Beratung habe wenn ich jetzt höre
dass ein großer Personalabbau droht dann
ist ja genau das warum ich vielleicht
noch in so einen Warenhaus gehe die
Beratung ja gar nicht mehr vorhanden für
die Mitarbeiter der Galeria Karstadt
Kaufhof Häuser beginnt jetzt schon
wieder die große Ungewissheit welches
Haus bleibt welches nicht innerhalb von
drei Monaten soll die Entscheidung
fallen so oder so waren Häuser in der
jetzigen Form sind angezählt
in die Ukraine dort geht die
Internationale Atomenergiebehörde
russischen Vorwürfen nach die Regierung
in Kiew wolle eine Bombe mit
radioaktiven Material einsetzen
überprüft werden da jetzt zwei Standorte
in der Stadt mikolaiw im Süden des
Landes sind vier russische Raketen
eingeschlagen eine Frau kam dabei ums
Leben in Kiew ist die Wasser- und
Stromversorgung nach raketentreffern
gestern in weiten Teilen
wiederhergestellt sagt die
Stadtverwaltung
Tag 2 der zentralasienreise von
Außenministerin berbock heute ist sie in
der Republik Usbekistan Usbekistan war
viele Jahre eine sowjetische
Teilrepublik und versucht seitdem
politisch und wirtschaftlich aus dem
Schatten Moskau heraus zu treten bärbock
hat schon vor der Reise deutlich gemacht
Deutschland suche sich nur neue
Geschäftspartner die auch in punkto
Menschenrechte auf Augenhöhe mit Europa
sind Patricia Wiedemeier berichtet
die Ressourcen an Rohstoffen sie
scheinen riesig zu sein in Usbekistan
Außenministerin bareburg sucht neue
Partner will Abhängigkeiten auf mehrere
Länder verteilen hier bieten sie sich
den deutschen an im bergbau- und
Eisenhütten Kombinat nahe Taschkent
werden alleine 148.000 Tonnen Kupfer
jährlich produziert wir können nicht nur
ganz Europa wir können auch die anderen
Länder versorgen weil wir hier nicht nur
Kupfer sondern auch Gold Silber und
andere Metalle produzieren
beide Seiten haben Interesse am Ausbau
der Beziehungen für bärbock jedoch
müssen EU-Standards bei den
Menschenrechten und Arbeitsbedingungen
eingehalten werden ihr Amtskollege
verspricht Reformen in Usbekistan hat
ein breit angelegter Reformprozess
begonnen Menschenrechte persönliche und
wirtschaftliche Rechte und Umweltschutz
sollen erstmalig in der Verfassung
verankert werden
dass Menschenrechte eingehalten werden
das fordert bärbock nicht nur von
Usbekistan das gelte auch für China oder
Scholz müsse bei seiner Reise nach
Peking Ende der Woche die verendete
china-strategie übermitteln
bekanntermaßen haben wir im
Koalitionsvertrag deutlich festgehalten
dass China für uns Partner bei globalen
Fragen ist dass wir uns nicht entkoppeln
können in einer globalisierten Welt dass
China aber auch Wettbewerber und in
zunehmendem Maße systemischer Rivale ist
es ist schon ein recht ungewöhnlicher
Vorgang dass die Außenministerin vor der
China-Reise des Kanzlers Forderungen
stellt es könnte die Folge der
Machtworte des Kanzlers sein im
Atomstreit und beim Thema Teilverkauf
des Hamburger Hafens die Stimmung
innerhalb der Ampelkoalition sie scheint
nicht gerade die Beste zu sein
das Thema Menschenrechte steht auch im
Mittelpunkt der katarreise von
bundesinnenministerin Phaser in knapp
drei Wochen startet dort die Fußball-WM
eine Weltmeisterschaft die seit Jahren
in der Kritik steht weil Wanderarbeiter
beim Bau von Stadion starben weil
Menschenrechte weniger zählen und so ist
der Besuch der Ministerin gemeinsam mit
dfb-vertretern ein Spagat Andreas Künast
in genau 21 Tagen und 19 Stunden geht
die WM für Deutschland los mit
Deutschland Japan im kalifa-stadion in
Doha Katar das so modern ist und so
gestrig dass die deutsche
Innenministerin die Vergabe der WM an
die autokratische autoritäre Monarchie
ganz grundsätzlich einen Fehler nannte
hat zu erheblichen diplomatischen
Verstimmungen geführt Katas
Außenministerium hat den deutschen
Botschafter Fischbach eingestellt
Deutschlands Außenministerium hat den
Besuch der Menschenrechtsbeauftragten
Amtsberg abgesagt so schlecht ist die
Stimmung das fesers Treffen mit ihrem
Amtskollegen nicht gefilmt werden darf
und das nicht der Gastgeber sondern der
Gast Katars Zusage verkündet also er hat
gesagt dass er alles dafür tun wird dass
die Sicherheit der Menschen garantiert
wird und auch zwar mit dieser
Formulierung egal an wen man glaubt egal
wie man liebt egal wo man herkommt die
Sicherheit Garantie für deutsche Fans
egal ob mit Schwarz-Rot-Gold oder
Regenbogenflagge war das eine Ziel von
faesers Reise ein Entschädigungsfonds
für Verstorbene oder verletzte Arbeiter
das andere nach den Gesprächen auch mit
fifa-Chef Infantino kommt die deutsche
Delegation der schadenersatzidee ein
Stückchen näher das ist schon dass man
sich wirklich ernsthaft Gedanken darüber
macht wie man das Aufsetzen kann das ist
ein komplexes Thema und das das Gefühl
haben wir auf jeden Fall mitgenommen zum
ersten Spiel der deutschen Mannschaft
will phesa wieder in Katar sein dann
soll es um Fußball gehen
zum fünften Mal in nur vier Jahren
finden heute Parlamentswahlen in Israel
statt dort will er wieder an die Macht
Benjamin netanjaro der ehemalige
Regierungschef könnte es knapp schaffen
allerdings wohl nur mit Unterstützung
ultra rechter Parteien auch der liberale
Amtsinhaber ja Lapid muss auf die
Stimmen Verbündeter hoffen er war im
Juni mit seiner Regierungskoalition aus
acht Parteien gescheitert die Wahllokale
schließen um 21 Uhr deutscher Zeit
Michael Beverungen in Tel Aviv die
Wahlbeteiligung ist die höchste seit
über 20 Jahren ist das ein Signal
na sie ist auf jeden Fall zum Abend noch
mal gestiegen man kann das auch hier an
dem regen Betrieb in einem Wahllokal
mitten in Tel Aviv hier sehen und der
Wahlkampf wird auch bis zur letzten
Minute noch sehr laut geführt was das
für Auswirkungen hat welchem Lager das
zugute kommt dass Marke niemand sagen
nach den letzten Umfragen sieht es
wieder mal nach einem politischen Part
aus mit einem leichten Vorteil für das
netanjahulago Lager das eine knappe
Mehrheit von einer Stimme erreichen
könnte die Frage ist wie es geht weiter
es müsste schon wenn es bei diesem Part
bleibt
netanjaro selbst sein der dieses Part
auflöst das heißt der verzichtet auf
seinen Machtanspruch oder wird
zurückgedrängt von seiner Partei denn
eigentlich können die anderen sehr gut
mit dem Liquid koalieren nur nicht mit
dem umstrittenen Ministerpräsidenten das
andere Szenario wäre das tatsächlich
eine tanjao mit seinem rechten Block
eine knappe Mehrheit erringt dann würden
zum ersten Mal bekennende
Rechtsextremisten und offene Rassisten
als Regierungsmitglieder am
Kabinettstisch sitzen das hätte
natürlich massive Konsequenzen das würde
die Spaltung dieses Landes noch viel
stärker vergrößern und natürlich auch
die Spannungen mit den partitionellen
verschärfen spannender wahlabende in
Israel danke Michael Bewohner nach Tel
Aviv und auch Dänemark wählt heute und
auch dort ist der Ausgang unklar auf
eine Wiederwahl hofft die
sozialdemokratische Ministerpräsidentin
Mette Frederiksen ihr Mitte Linksbündnis
liegt gleich auf mit einem Mitte
rechtsbündnis um Jakob Element Jensen
wichtige Themen im Wahlkampf waren die
Gesundheitspolitik und die hohen
Energiepreise
ja es ist eine Erfolg für Ex-Präsident
Trump die Herausgabe seiner
Steuerunterlagen an das
Repräsentantenhaus wurde vom obersten
US-Gericht dem Supreme Court vorerst
gestoppt der Kongressausschuss hat jetzt
bis zum 10 November Zeit Umstellung zu
beziehen seit Jahren versuchen die
Demokraten im Kongress die
Steuererklärungen von Trump einzusehen
nach der Präsidentenwahl in Brasilien
verdichten sich die Hinweise das
wahlverlehrer Bolz sonaro die Niederlage
wohl nicht anfechten wird dass zumindest
bestätigte ein Regierungsmitglied wollte
zu naro will sich in Kürze äußern seine
Anhänger errichteten auch heute aus
Protest in fast allen Landesteilen
Straßensperren der Wahlsieger Lula wird
zu Beginn des kommenden Jahres sein Amt
antreten
nach den Protestanten gestern beginnen
heute die Katholiken einen hohen
Feiertag zu Allerheiligen gedenken sie
der Heiligen und Verstorbenen wie hier
in Rheinland-Pfalz besuchten viele
Menschen Gräber ihrer Angehörigen und
zündeten Kerzen an mit Gebeten Ehren sie
die Toten und bitten um deren Erlösung
in fünf Bundesländern ist Allerheiligen
ein gesetzlicher Feiertag
wir sind jetzt beim Sport wieder eine
Champions league-woche und besonders
spannend wird es für die Eintracht
Frankfurt Fans und natürlich auch für
die Fußballer wirklich alles passen tja
wohin geht die Reise für den Europa
league-gewinner aus Frankfurt fakt ist
die Eintracht hat es selbst in der Hand
und weiß dass bei Sporting Lissabon
gewonnen werden muss um zum ersten Mal
in die k.o.-runde der Königsklasse
einzuziehen
ein Endspiel wieder einmal für die
Eintracht ein Sieg in Lissabon Mann
stünde im Achtelfinale wieder was
historisches was wir schaffen können
aber ohne Druck sondern er mit viel
Freude würde aber massiv gegen Tottenham
gewinnen und die Eintracht spielt
Unentschieden wäre Frankfurt als Vierter
ausgeschieden verlassen uns lieber auf
uns selbst und werden auf Sieg spielen
ein Unentschieden hilft nur für Platz
drei und die Europa League wenn
Marseille nicht gewinnt
also wahrlich spannende Konstellationen
0:3 wurde das Hinspiel gegen sporting
verloren belarethy in Lissabon
Entschuldigung was spricht diesmal für
die Eintracht
für die Eintracht spielt der sie
inzwischen Champions League kann das war
gegen sporting das erste Spiel das war
nur so eine Übungsspiel zum ersten Mal
überhaupt das erste Champions League
Spiel der Geschichte gegen Lissabon
inzwischen ist die Eintracht eingespielt
gut in Form ist immer für Tore gut und
werde das denn gedacht nach der
Auslosung dass am letzten Spieltag alles
noch möglich ist und dass die
Frankfurter Eintracht aus eigener Kraft
ohne fremde Hilfe das Achtelfinale
erreichen kann hier im Stadion Jose
alvarlade in Lissabon Bela vielen Dank
für diese Einstimmung alle Höhepunkte
Tore und stimmen und Analysen zum
Abschluss der Gruppenphase morgen Abend
von 23 Uhr an hier bei uns im ZDF
Sportstudio Eva Champions League die
Frauen des SC Potsdam haben den Supercup
im Volleyball gewonnen bei der siebten
Auflage dieses Wettbewerbs setzten sich
im Finale die Potsdamerinnen auswärts
bei den favorisierten Meisterinnen und
pokalsiegerinnen vom MTV Stuttgart
überraschend in drei zu Einsätzen durch
ein verheißungsvoller Saisoneinstieg
immerhin der erste große Titelgewinn für
die Potsdamerin na denn Dankeschön
Christin wir haben das noch zum Wetter
da ist mehr Wind angesagt aber mehr
erfahren Sie gleich von oerstin Terry um
21 Uhr noch mal eine aktuelle Einordnung
der Nachrichtenlage mit Christian
Sievers im heute-journal ja das war es
von uns schönen Dank schönen Abend und
bis morgen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter ein extremer Monat
liegt hinter uns in Frankreich in
Österreich und in der Schweiz war es der
wärmste seit
Aufzeichnungsbeginn für Deutschland gilt
das wird entweder Platz 1 oder Platz 2
morgen veröffentlicht der Deutsche
Wetterdienst die Daten und dann wissen
wir es genauer die Klimakrise lässt
grüßen die Luft kommt mittlerweile aus
westlichen Richtungen und ist nicht mehr
ganz so warm dafür kommt sie relativ
schnell der Wind liegt ordentlich zu und
es wird stürmisch in der nachts wird es
schon windig im Nordwesten Richtung
Nordsee ansonsten kommt auch Regen auf
es bildet Zeit sich teilweise nach Süden
hinnebel teilweise klar ist auch auf und
die Temperaturen sinken auf 4 Grad ganze
im Süden und 12 Grad ganz im Westen
morgen am Vormittag dann weitere Regen
im Nordwesten und auch Gewitter sind
dabei dazu stürmischer Wind an der
Nordsee in den Bergen und im binnland im
Süden muss noch der Nebel sondern wird
es sonniger bei Temperaturen bis zu 17
Grad im Südwesten und teilweise 12 Grad
zum Beispiel in Schleswig-Holstein die
nächsten Tage mit ist es noch am
Donnerstag bis 17 Grad mit einigen
Schauern deutlich mehr Regen dann ab
Freitag und kühler ein schöner Abend